good I wanted to do a video was a bit
bored but I didn't know what I wanted to
do a video on and these people I'm like
Twitter or like balloon so hey here we
are talking about the new Suicide Squad
trailer it's kind of funny because can
we just address the rock and roll
standoff that the movie trailer world's
having right now guardians of the galaxy
was on Star Trek beyond was like oh yeah
we'll get sabotage I get it was a
throwback to the first Star Trek movie
but it was a little strange suicide
squads like yeah we'll have Queen
Bohemian Rhapsody is chaotic as [ __ ]
which makes a pretty solid
representation about the Suicide Squad
should probably feel like which we see
all these baddies who are locked up get
black bagged and then thrown into this
undisclosed location that will probably
be disclosed in the movie Harley Quinn's
talking crazy Deadshot doesn't have his
oscar nomination but his wife forgot
pissed which again this is a trailer
it's gonna set up the tone but I like
the tone I mean we do not live in a
Christopher Nolan comic book world any
more folks this we're now past that this
is a movie that is fully embracing its
comic-book lore which is really cool
enchantress has this like black mass or
around her all the time is that just
when she's honing her craft are we gonna
see her like that all the time that's
pretty neat effect and again I don't
really know who they're going up against
I mean are they just did they assemble
this Suicide Squad to go take out the
Joker okay you see this thing we're like
this bus is melted or some [ __ ] you're
like well either Joker has a really big
gun or it's something that one of the
members of the Suicide Squad did or
there's something else you know what I
have a soft spot for our trailers that
use music that have the scenes in the
trailer cut together to the beat or save
the world
sounds simple enough but a lot of
trailers don't do that so when a trailer
does I'm like I like that I got to talk
about the joke in here a couple of sweet
Joker scenes where he's like I can't
wait to show you my toy do what Jack
says I did like to see we're using the
tuxedo shooting that machine gun adjust
that just it looked like Joker meets Al
Capone I love that scene where Joker
Swan dives it's just like a really cool
shot but that looks like he's what is he
baptizing Harley Quinn or some things
that when he creates Hurley Quinn or is
this like - Harley Quinn die no I
wouldn't do that [ __ ] but or does he
save Harley's life which okay Jai
Kourtney's in this movie he plays
Captain Boomerang if this doesn't work
out for me if he sucks as Captain
Boomerang Hollywood can we just stop
trying to make Jai Courtney happen I
only say that because Jai Courtney
that being said Jai Courtney I hope
you're an awesome Captain Boomerang yeah
I thought this new Suicide Squad trailer
that was a pretty fun trailer - a movie
that should be fun
my guys are the new Suicide Squad
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it wherever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more